[Music]
you can expect fans of the book crazy
rich Asians to run to the theater when
the movie opens August 15th there is so
much excitement for this movie by the
way I got to point this out not since
1993 Joy Luck Club has a film featured
an all-asian cast you know what though
there is one actor in particular
generating a lot of heat here is why
everybody is talking about the movies
leading man Henry Golding Andrey Golding
who's this you know very exciting actor
he's certainly caught Blake Lively's eye
Henry is playing her husband in a simple
favor which is only his second movie
ever after crazy rich Asians this is
your first movie it's my first movie
absolute diva you guys know the rights
of the hells yeah
there's just the biggest developers in
all of Singapore I patient bachelor the
comedy is expected to be a sleeper hit
Forbes calling it this summer's girls
trip and while Henry's better known
co-stars like fresh off the boats
Constance Wu the hangovers ken Jeong and
oceans eights Aquafina may be used to
get in this kind of crazy u.s. press not
this guy you two also were on the cover
of Entertainment Weekly
my first big cover the fact that people
were picking on it before any footage
was coming out I was blown away and that
just shows how much faith the industry
had
anybody know where Henry is yeah so just
who is this new leading man he's 31
married and a former hairstylist who's
also very comfortable in front of the
camera thank you for joining us on all
of our travels
Henry was a TV host in Asia fronting
several travel series and built up quite
a following while shooting this movie in
his home country of Malaysia was a treat
it wasn't as glam as it looks
three-piece suits filming in Asia it was
just like a steam bar and you would just
just be sweating you sweat it out
[Music]